how it started and how it's going FTX
cryptocurrency exchange Sam bankman
freed is the child of academics since he
was a student he dreamed of becoming a
21st century Robin Hood in 2017 he
founded his own company an investment
fund named Alameda research in order to
not miss those crucial moments and close
a profitable deal he lived in his office
and pretty much never left his computer
in 2019 he opened a second company the
FTX crypto exchange soon FTX was among
the top three largest exchanges however
Sam was in no hurry to donate everything
he earned in fact he gave just 0.1
percent of his fortune away to charity
in November 2022 the media discovered an
8 billion hole in the Alameda research
budget reporting that bankman patched it
with FTX funds this confusion led to
panic and people began to withdraw their
savings on mass as a result FTX was
forced to declare itself bankrupt how
did this happen maybe it was because
according to Media reports bankman
played computer games during ftx's
presentations to investors what do you
think about the collapse of FTX